five billion pounds that sounds like a
lot of money doesn't it but let's just
try and put it into some sort of contest
comparing it with the money that we are
already planning to spend this year on
covet 19 so you can see the five billion
pounds the Prime Minister's been talking
about so far but let's look at the
amounts of cash that we're spending
already and pledging to spend on covet
19 you've got five billion pounds going
towards loan write-offs add on 56
billion pounds on top of that spent on
the furlough scheme on top of that
you've got 23 billion pounds going on
extra welfare payments another 15
billion pounds going to small businesses
15 billion pounds on top of that go
being spent on the NHS and other
spending and another five billion on top
you get the idea here we're talking
about an enormous tower of spending
bringing it to about one hundred and
nineteen billion pounds of extra
spending extra spending that's about
equivalent to six percent of GDP now
whenever that six percent of gdp let's
put that into a bit of historical
context and I'll put that six percent
over there so that's extra spending what
we're gonna see here is how that stacks
up to a bigger deficit borrowing this
year so 16 extra spending then you've
got six point five percent of GDP that's
the fall in tax receipts so money that
isn't coming into the external top of
that you've got the existing deficit
that was already expected this year now
taught that all up and you're talking
about 15 percent of GDP that is an
enormous deficit to give you a sense of
how enormous let's compare it to the
financial crisis you know previously
these were seen as some of the biggest
deficits we'd ever had in the UK but
actually this year will be worse bigger
in terms of deficit than any year in the
financial crisis and bigger too a lot of
talk about FDR Roosevelt the New Deal
the 1930s this is bigger than any single
year of Roosevelt's New Deal as well in
terms of a deficit it's worth saying
it's a bit different because there's a
lot of this was investment spending
whereas a lot of this as we've just seen
is spending on welfare and other things
but it is a lot of money how is the
Prime Minister going to actually pay for
it well here's his answer what we're
saying is that this is the moment to
make that big big long term stake that
that backing of Britain because that
will deliver the long term productivity
gains the gains that will in the end
deliver the tax revenues though of
course
we're going to need so in short the
answer is productivity extra
productivity growth that comes from that
investment fuels tax revenues that's the
idea but the problem is have a look at
the history of productivity over the
course of the last few years look at
those white lines every government over
the past decade has expected
productivity to magically rise bringing
in those extra cash to the Exchequer but
instead look it's flat lines and the
concern is that might well happen this
time around it might be that the Prime
Minister is lucky but it hasn't happened
so far each year everyone has been a
little bit disappointed